une autre liste sans étiquette pour ces
élections municipales à villepreux celle
menée par vous valérie bain dont soir
ensemble vous êtes la tête de liste
d'agir avec vous pour vil prix une liste
qui se veut citoyenne ouverte et
participative et c'est une liste qui
regroupe des habitants des commerçants
des acteurs du secteur associatif mais
aussi deux conseillers municipaux
actuels d'opposition l'idée c'est que ce
soit une candidature plurielle qui
unissent les forces
finalement oui alors la liste elle s'est
d'abord créé sur les projets
effectivement nos idées ont attiré des
gens qui étaient de tous les milieux de
tous les environs de tous les quartiers
donc voilà comment ça s'est passé
c'est un processus qui remonte à un an
cette constitution de listes
on a commencé effectivement bon tout est
parti du projet central park donc de la
phase de pseudo concertation qui a été
organisée et voilà petit à petit on
s'est regroupé les uns avec les autres
et on s'est aperçu que au delà du projet
de central park y avait d'autres projets
sur lesquels on pouvait proposer une
alternative à ce que nous donnait la
majorité de l'époque on parlera tout à
l'heure de ce projet central park vous
êtes à titre personnel valérie bain un
soutien de la république en marche c'est
ce que ça ça ne rentrent pas en ligne de
compte dans cette liste il ya aucune
investiture qui est revendiquée oui
alors donc moi je dirige un collectif en
fait et ce qui m'intéresse c'est les
projets au niveau de la municipalité ces
projets là on parle de sécurité on parle
de santé on parle d'urbanisme ça va
au-delà en fait des étiquettes
politiques
donc je dirige une liste citoyenne
ouverte et plurielle et voilà il n'y a
pas d'autre
il n'y a pas de soutien ni de loin ni de
près sur notre liste citoyenne
il ya un autre angle affiché aussi dans
cette candidature c'est de promouvoir la
démocratie participative
comment vous verriez les habitants
davantage associés à la décision
communale est ce que ce peut-être au
travers par exemple de budget
participatif comme on peut voir fleurir
sur d'autres communes comment comment
vous voyez les choses alors ben là on
voit en période d'élection que tout le
monde va à la rencontre des villes
provient donc ils sont extrêmement
sollicités on leur demande leur avis et
c'est donc là l'idée c'est d'avoir si
dynamique mais tout au long du mans
de communiquer sur les propositions et
puis donc des délais les villes provient
qui le souhaitent à monter des projets
avec l'appui de l'équipe municipale
allait présenter en fait à la
municipalité enfin aux habitants d'île
pr qui eux-mêmes définiront les
priorités puisque effectivement on ne
pourra pas tout faire en même temps
et effectivement en fonction des projets
s'il ya des projets qui n'ont pas besoin
de financement et s'il ya des besoins
des projets qui ont besoin de
financement
il y aura une partie du budget qui sera
soutenue mais ça ce sont les villes
provient qui arbitreront entre les
projets et au niveau des enveloppes
budgétaires
non juste avant de parler de vos
priorités votre regard quel regard vous
portez sur les deux ans les deux mandats
pendant les deux mandats effectués par
le maire stéphanie rambaud qui est donc
maire depuis 2008
écoutez il ya il ya des choses qui sont
bien qu'ils ont avancés comme au niveau
national il ya beaucoup de communes qui
ont qui ont avancé sur justement les
pesticides sur le les cantines bio fin
voilà donc tout ça c'est des choses qui
sont favorables à la population après
nous le problème qu'on assure villepreux
c'est la multiplication des programmes
immobiliers dont on ne voit vraiment pas
le sens et les ça on n'arrive pas à
comprendre ou veut nous emmener cette
municipalité via le programme central
park notamment que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure un écoquartier de 19 mille
mètres carrés dans le secteur du trianon
et de l'ex rda 298 ça c'est un projet
que vous voulez je les ai en tout cas
c'est l'une de vos promesses si vous
êtes élu pourquoi il faut il faut
l'arrêter
aujourd'hui ce projet en fait là on
vient d'avoir un quartier qui s'appelle
les eaux du moulin avec une première
tranche de à peu près 500 logements
on attend une deuxième tranche de 500
logements donc on arrive déjà à 1000
logements à intégrer dans ce quartier là
on our propose à nouveau
250 logements dans cet espace de verdure
en nous expliquant qu'en mettant des
bâtiments on va augmenter l'espace vert
donc pour nous là on est dans une crise
de croissance au niveau de la ville il
faut déjà qu'on absorbe en fait les
nouveaux arrivants de villepreux qui
sont les bienvenus qu'on leur fasse
partager notre qualité de vie et nos
valeurs et après on pourra réfléchir à
est-ce qu'on a encore vraiment besoin de
transformer ces espaces verts en
immeuble ça a l'air d'aller un peu à
contre sens en fait avec ce que
demandent les
il provient on précise tout de même que
la loi impose un quota de 25 % de
logements sociaux à l'horizon 2025
aujourd'hui villepreux et aux alentours
des 20 % les communes qui ne respectent
pas ces rythme de construction se voit
infliger des pénalités comment on
compose avec cette contrainte imposée
par l'état est aussi respecté la
transition écologique voilà comment on a
dit tout ça et comment on respecte ses
contraintes de l'état
alors ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
fini assez paradoxal mais quand vous
construisez sans logement et que du coup
vous vous faites 25 logements sociaux et
bien comme au total vous avez augmenté
le nombre de logements vous quelque part
vous le pourcentage que vous gagnez
minimes en fait donc la seule façon
c'est d'eux que nous on envisage c'est
de construire de toutes petites unités
mais uniquement de par exemple dix
logements sociaux voilà cent pour cent
logements sociaux sur dix logements
ça fait plus de bénéfices en fait que de
construire 25 % de logements sur une
unité de 80 alors c'est une alternative
à ce qui est proposé actuellement l'une
de vos priorités également c'est l'offre
culturelle vous souhaitez donner un
nouveau souffle aux théâtres de villes
prusse un équipement de 430 places quel
est le problème avec son ex avec ce lieu
et je ne sais pas quel est le problème
en tous les cas la municipalité actuelle
avait accès énormément ses
investissements sur le sport et sert à
la culture était
il n'a pas mis de côté elle a été
ignorée pendant deux mandats donc voila
nous on a intégré la sky depuis 2016 on
voit bien que les offres culturelles
sont organisées et on se dit qu'avec ce
magnifique théâtre de 430 places mais on
doit pouvoir faire quelque chose il faut
davantage travailler sur ce sujet avec
la la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
oui bah c'est absolument une ressource
pour nous en fait cette communauté
d'agglo voilà la vocation c'est de faire
des économies d'échelle de mutualiser
des moyens donc nous on veut absolument
aller dans ce sens là pour l'ensemble
des sujets qui concerne la municipalité
et la communauté d'agglo mais en
particulier pour la culture
mais justement villepreux fait partie de
l'agglomération depuis 2016 quel regard
vous portez sur le travail mené au sein
de cette agglomération sur la place
aussi de villepreux occupe dans cette
agglomération je précise que la commune
était plutôt bien représentée avec le
maire stephen vieux mirambeau qu'à une
vice-présidence aux finances est
également sylvie ce vraiment elle qui a
une délégation à l'école innovantes et à
la modernisation pédagogique
quelle quelle place enfin quel regard
vous portez sur cette place de
villepreux l'a écoutée sur ces sujets là
qui sont traités et forcément il avance
avec les autres mais d'une façon
générale nous dans le cadre de la
préparation de cette campagne tous les
experts qu'on sollicite au niveau de la
sky news
on s'aperçoit que finalement il ya des
compétences à la sky et que l on peu
accès en fait aux villes provient donc
je pense que le rôle de la municipalité
par exemple pour la rénovation
énergétique
il faut que plus qu'on permette à ces
expertises qui sont au niveau de la sky
de diffuser leurs messages de faire
bénéficier l'ensemble des villes preuve
davantage de pédagogie expliquer les
compétences de l'agglomération
exactement faire du lien par exemple
l'école des eaux du moulin qui est
actuellement construite là une école de
16 classes elle est construite
uniquement par la municipalité sans le
soutien des équipes techniques de la sky
c'est quelque part une aberration
un dernier mot on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien votre prochain rendez vous de
campagne alors nous invitons tous les
villes provient à venir nous rejoindre à
notre réunion publique samedi prochain
25 janvier à 16h à la nex et puis pour
ceux qui ne pourraient pas venir il ya
une prochaine réunion qui aura lieu le
samedi 29 février aussi et enfin une
dernière réunion
le samedi 7 mars vous pouvez aussi nous
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux ou venir
à notre rencontre nous sommes souvent
présents sur le marché
merci valérie belin tête de liste d'agir
avec vous pour villepreux et outre votre
candidature et celle de sylvie se
démantèle dont on parlait tout à l'heure
la candidature aussi l du maire sortant
stéphane mirambeau celle du délégué
départemental du modem jean baptiste à
monique enfin kouros gaulle bolat qui
conduira la liste tout simplement
villepreux